a British tanker that Iran had detained
his now on the move and leaving Iranian
waters the stoner in Poirot has started
transmitting its location for the first
time in weeks
its owners say they'll comment further
when the oil tanker reaches
international waters the stoner in Peru
left iran's Bandar Abbas port where it
was taken after being seized in July
according to the Reuters news agency the
ship has set its destination as Portrush
Eid in the United Arab Emirates
well Iran's Revolutionary Guards seized
the ship in the Strait of Hormuz two
months ago Tehran said it had violated
maritime rules but its owner says the
company isn't aware of any formal
charges who was detained just weeks
after British military seized an Iranian
oil tanker in Gibraltar well let's go
live to our correspondent Zane booth
Ravi now who's in Tehran Zane what more
do we know about the ship well Nev what
we've been hearing in the last hour is
reports quoting the owner of the Stena
Impero stand-up bulk and they've said
that they're expecting the ship to reach
international waters by 10:00 GMT so
just in a matter of approximately an
hour earlier this morning we heard from
local port authorities in Hormuz gun
province at Bunder Abbas port who had
said that they had carried out the order
to release the ship at approximately
9:00 a.m. local Iran time 5:30 GMT so
that would make sense that the Sten and
Peres will reach the UAE in just a
matter of one hour what the reports
quoting the owner of the vessel have
also been saying is that there is a
well-prepared security plan in place
once the ship reaches international
waters of course then we know that the
US is putting in place a maritime
coalition to secure the waters of the
Gulf Iran also now saying it's putting
forward its own peace initiative for the
region how does the release of the ship
all play into this
well what we heard from the owner saying
that there was a security plan in place
really does it really is just the tip of
the iceberg it scratches the surface
here there is a great deal of concern
for the security of the vessel despite
Iranian assurances that they would
release it and now that it has been
released
Iran made overtures by releasing early
on seven members of the crew that were
non-essential on humanitarian grounds
but there is still a great deal of a
lack of certainty when it comes to Iran
and ships navigating this waterway of
the United States of course after
attacks earlier this year on oil tankers
that they blamed on Iran we have to say
there hasn't been any evidence produced
to suggest so but it were United States
and its regional allies blamed oil
tanker attacks on Iran earlier this year
and called for an international
coalition ahead of going to the UN
General Assembly Iran's president Hassan
rouhani said that he had his own plan
his own peace initiative for security in
the Hormuz Strait that would involve
only the regional actors the countries
in and around the waterways of the Gulf
and that is exactly what he proposed at
the UN he has said that foreign minister
Javad Zarif will stay behind in New York
to discuss the exact details of that
plan with other world leaders at the UN
General Assembly president Hassan
rouhani is due to land back in Tehran
later today and it does not seem that
the release of the ship is necessarily a
coincidence it seems like a coordinated
plan for the release of this vessel to
help complement the plan that Zarif will
make to suggest to world leaders that
Iran is the main stakeholder and the
main provider of security and should
lead the way for the security of this
waterway Zane thank you very much name
is Ravi in Tehran